hey guys it's Justine and do you know
what time it is I do because I've got
two brand new watches on my wrist the
Apple Watch series 9 and the Apple watch
Ultra
[Music]
2 now you may know and I've said this so
many times on my channel that other than
my iPhone the Apple watch is my favorite
Apple product of all time and I think
this is actually true for a lot of
people and that's probably because Apple
has put so much effort into this piece
of tech to make it so much more than
just a smartwatch they are consistently
updating their watch lines with awesome
features and improving the hardware with
each new release making them truly
invaluable tools for me personally the
Apple watch has helped me stay on top of
my fitness goals and it even inspired me
to try new activities that I probably
never would have thought to try
otherwise but we'll talk more about that
later both of these watches are powered
by the new S9 sip which has a four core
neural engine enabling some new features
that we have haven't seen in the Apple
watch up until now Siri can now handle
the most common tasks directly on the
device rather than having to connect to
the internets which means hopefully it
will be faster and easier to use Siri on
the watch you can also Access Health
Data via Siri now which is great
although that feature won't be coming
out until later this year so I'm excited
to try that out and thanks to the second
gen Ultra wideband chip Precision
finding has been improved so now when
you need to find your iPhone in addition
to hearing that wonderful chirp sound
that we're all so familiar with the
Apple watch will show you the approxim
imate distance and direction to your
phone I lose my phone at least 10 times
a day so I'm pretty stoked about that
another new feature coming to the Apple
watch is name drop which Apple announced
during WWDC for iOS 17 I love this
feature so it's pretty cool that they're
bringing this over to the watch OS as
well you can get the Apple Watch series
9 in either aluminum or stainless steel
finishes for aluminum you can choose
between midnight Starlight silver
product red and of course my favorites
pink and for stainless steel it comes in
Gold Silver and graphite both the Apple
Watch series 9 n and Ultra 2 now have
brighter screens as well with a series 9
going up to 2,000 nits which is double
the brightness of the series 8 and the
ultra 2 is going up to 3,000 nits which
is 50% brighter than the original even
with the new brighter screen with the
Apple watch Ultra 2 you're still getting
36 hours of battery life and if you have
it in low power mode you can get up to
72 hours which is pretty long time if
you think about it but the big new
feature they announced for the Apple
watch is double tap and this allows you
to control the Apple watch handsfree now
I got to try this out during the product
demo and it's super cool all you have to
do is raise your wrist and double tap
your thumb and index finger and this
action controls the primary button in
any app so you can do things like pause
and play music answer a call open a
notification and there's tons of other
operations now when you're at the home
screen a double tap will open up your
smart stack so you can scroll through
all of your open notifications and
widgets I think this is a really cool
feature and it's probably just the first
of many gesture-based features that
Apple will bring to the Apple watch in
the future now I also know that this is
a feature that was in accessibility
previously but that is something that
you had to turn on it wasn't a
full-fledged built out feature now
they're taking advantage of all of the
new Hardware in the Apple watch they
have the ability to make this a
wide-based feature and it's actually
something that you don't have to turn on
it just works a big point of Pride for
Apple this year is that both of the new
Apple watches are their first 100%
carbon neutral product this is part of
their 2030 plan to make their entire
product line carbon neutral by 2030 you
are able to tell what products are
carbon neutral by by looking at this
little logo right here and this sport
Loop one is actually one of my new
favorites and I love how soft it is
they're using all different types of
recycled materials like old threads that
they didn't use from previous watch
bands and even these Nike ones for
example these are also made from
recycled groundup old Apple watch bands
that they either didn't use or they're
just excess materials that didn't make
the cut while I was at the Apple event I
got a chance to sit down with Lisa
Jackson and John turnis from Apple to
learn more about their environmental
initiatives you can check that video out
here if you want to watch more now last
year Apple released the Apple watch
Ultra which was such a huge hit and for
me it quickly became my watch of choice
for my daily use honestly when I first
got it I thought it was going to be way
too big for my little wrist but I got
over that pretty quickly I love this
thing so much and even though we didn't
get a design change or a new color
option with the ultra 2 there's still
some really great new features the first
thing that I noticed in using this is
how much brighter the new screen is and
it really does make a huge difference
especially when you're outside in the
bright Sun now like I said before it is
now brighter with a peak brightness of
3,000 knits and it also comes with an
improved ambient light sensor the
display will adapt to your surrounding
lighting conditions and it can dim down
to just one knit for night mode this is
the new modular Ultra watch face which
takes advantage of a huge display this
has the most complications of any watch
face I mean look at this they're
everywhere the compass has also been
reimagined with new tools and
functionality you can see important
details like elevation incline and even
a 3D view of your waypoints on a trail
now of course the Apple watch Ultra was
designed designed specifically for the
most extreme kinds of activities it can
handle the most harsh environments
extreme hot and cold wet and dry high
elevation you name it and it just so
happens that I recently took on one of
these extreme activities as my new hobby
scuba diving all right friends we were
here in Catalina and it's time to go
diving with the brand new Apple watch
Ultra 2 and the iPhone 15
[Music]
PR
oh my God it's so cold so when you're
actually underwater when you're using
this as a dive computer it'll give you
your depth water temperature and it also
gives you an alert when it's time to do
your safety stop it'll also give you
notifications if you're descending or
ascending too quickly which is really
useful because sometimes you're just
focusing on either taking photos or just
trying to get your buoyancy correct so
being able to have this little extra
notification is really useful something
else that's pretty awesome if you don't
have an Apple Watch Ultra but you do
have an iPhone you are able to now turn
that into a dive computer as well with
Oceanic plus housing I did a full video
on this as well if you want to check
that out I just now want to encourage
everyone to be a diver and get into
scuba because it is so much fun like I
can't stop talking about it obviously if
you can't tell like I just that's all I
want to do that's all I want to talk
about and it's all thanks to the Apple
watch
[Music]
Ultra if it wasn't for the Apple watch
Ultra there's no way that I would doing
this at all I was terrified of water a
few months ago and now it's my new
favorite activity ever you can also set
it up if you want to just snorkel and
there's a new addition to do free diving
which is something that I haven't tried
yet so maybe one day soon I'm not sure
not going to hold my breath on that one
see what I did there yeah is that good
that's good so that my friends is the
brand new Apple watches and some of the
new features again I can't stress enough
how much I absolutely love the Apple
watch Ultra too so excited to do some
more adventures and I really want to get
back into hiking but now that I'm diving
I just want to be under the water if you
want to watch any other Apple videos or
anything else on my channel I'll put
some right here and I look forward to
seeing you guys in the next video bye